You,
you might've heard about bf skinner,
you know,
he used food pellets to motivate his
rats,
but what you don't know about skinner is
that those rats were starved to three
quarters of their normal body weight.
So they would,
they would work for food and so
skinner's routes were kind of
oversimplified,
but you can get rats to work for food.
They don't have to be that hungry.
You can get them to work for food and
they'll do all sorts of things.
They'll press leavers and,
and they'll open our open doors and
they'll solve problems and you know,
they'll do all sorts of things and one
of the things you can do to kind of
measure how much the rat is motivated
is,
let's say you've run them through a maze
and he knows there's some food at the
end of the maze.
You can tie a little spring to his tail
and see how hard he polls when you
opened the door to the maze.
So that's because that's how much rat
work the route is willing to do.
So you can measure that or you can see
how fast he skitters down in the maze
and you can get an estimate about the
rats motivation and so then you might
say,
well how motivated is a hungry rat?
And the answer would be depends on how
hungry is,
but there's another answer.
It also depends on what's chasing him
when he's going after the food.
So if you have a rat and you have food
over here and you walked in,
some cat older rats,
hate cat odor,
and it's innate.
They never have to see or smell acat to
be absolutely petrified by cat odor.
And so if you walked in some cat odor
and then opened the door,
that rat will zoom to that food a lot
faster than it will if it's just hungry.
So a rat running away from something
that it doesn't want toward something
that it does want is a very motivated
rat.
And so one of the things we did with the
future authoring program that's Germane
to this idea of terror,
because there's a.
there's this idea in the Old Testament,
the fear of God is the beginning of
wisdom and it's a pretty harsh idea,
but,
but there's something really useful
about it because one of the things you
see with people all the time is that
there maybe they're trying to stumble
forward towards their ideal as poorly
defined as it might be,
but then they're afraid,
right?
They're afraid about what they might
encounter and that stops them because
fear does stop people.
It freezes you like a prey on them and
so people move ahead,
but then they get afraid and then they
start moving ahead and so,
and that's not so good because negative
emotion is a really powerful motivator.
So we're more motivated by negative
emotion than positive emotion.
Quantitatively speaking,
quantitative,
quantitatively speaking.
You can measure that and that's I think
because we can only be so happy,
but we can really be suffering and
death,
you know,
so we have to pay more attention to the
negative.
And that's bad because the negative can
stop you.
And then my clinical practice,
you know,
I often talk to people who are trying to
make a difficult life decision and,
and they are weighing out the costs and
the benefits of making the life
decisions,
you know,
and one of the things I always talk to
them about is wait a second,
that's an incomplete analysis.
You have to weigh out the benefits and
the costs of doing this and you have to
weigh out the costs and benefits of not
doing that,
not doing it.
And that's not the same as the zero that
you assume that you're with,
right?
Because to not make a decision,
it also has a cost and sometimes the
cost of not making a decision is far
worse than the cost of making a
decision,
even if the decision is risky.
And so one of the things you can derive
from that,
and this is very useful,
I think,
is that
this is also,
I think why it's so useful to
contemplate your mortality,
so to speak,
as you're screwed,
no matter what you do,
you know,
and that actually frees you,
is that you,
you have power.
Hey,
that has catastrophes,
and you have path b that has
catastrophes and you don't get to have
the no catastrophe path,
but you get to pick which one and that's
really something because if you know
that there's terrible risk associated
with everything that you do and don't
do,
then you can afford to take some risks
because you're not,
you know,
this is all within the arc metaphor.
I'm still making the case that despite
the fact that your life is essentially
catastrophic,
you can,
you can make a covenant with the highest
ideal and that will take you through it
the best way possible.
I'm,
I'm still making that case.
So.
So then you think,
okay,
well I'm trying to make this decision,
I'm going to go try to do something
difficult and isn't that terrifying?
And then you think,
yeah,
but wait a minute,
what's really terrifying is not doing
it.
And then you think about the cost of not
doing it.
So in the future authoring program,
we have people do this little meditative
exercise,
which is okay,
just think about your insufficiencies by
your own definition,
right?
The way that you don't do what you know
you should do about the things that you
do that you shouldn't do,
that you know you shouldn't do beyond a
shadow of a doubt,
right?
There's some things like that and that
that's bad habits and poor aim and all
of the resentment and hatred and
aggression and unresolved conflicts and
all those things that are demanding you
in warping.
You then think,
okay,
those things get the upper hand man,
they get the upper hand and they take
you the worst possible place you could
go in the next three to five years.
What exactly does that look like?
And so you sketch all that out and you
think,
hey,
I don't want to go there.
And so the next time that attempt
Taishan comes up,
you think,
well,
it'd be a lot better for me if I didn't
succumb to this temptation.
It's like,
that's Kinda weak.
You'd look a little better if you didn't
eat like a cheese cake a day or
something like that.
You know,
that's something,
but it's not the same as,
um,
I'm going to have diabetes and I'm going
to lose my damn leg and in five years if
I don't get my eating under control,
that's motivating and so then the
temptation comes along and you think,
oh,
how about no,
seriously,
not just because a higher good would be
obtained if I avoided it,
but because of a terrible catastrophe
would be averted if I didn't,
and so well.
So you want to get your fear behind you,
right?
You want to get it behind you where it's
pushing you forward instead of in front
of you where it's stopping you and you
get your fear behind you,
pushing you forward by actually thinking
through the consequences of not putting
your life together and the the least of
those is that you and suffer right?
Because you're going to suffer anyways,
man,
so you wasted and suffer.
That's a bad deal because maybe if
you're going to suffer,
you could at least do something noble
and Glorious and upright and powerful
and honorable and admirable and helpful
and difficult.
You know?
It's just so much better and maybe
that's good enough so that you think,
hey,
you know,
little suffering,
it's basically worth it.
At least it's a way forward,
you know?
At least it's a way forward.